now gentlemen I want to ask you this at
that point
Frank was arriving but you had arrived
the two of you were at and still are you
were at the height of your game you easy
reader and then street-smart and then
crazy Joe Clarke and then glory and Tim
you were Merlin and Top Gun so he had
nothing to lose but you guys you had
reputations so what what specifically
wasn't about this that you said we're in
who you asking I'm asking both of you
what what made you say yes to this
project it was an incredible script yes
uh I read the script without knowing
which character I was being told to read
for nobody told me
which character read for really know so
when I read the script I called my agent
and said whatever didn't really matter
to me and then he said no no they want
you to play read which still blows my
mind they wouldn't they didn't tell him
what part we were sending him to a
script for I didn't know I didn't know
I'm agents always say of course we told
him he knows didn't know but then what I
did know why I was like ok I own this
funny that's what I thought too yeah it
was a beautiful script Frank wrote a
truly extraordinary script and I would
suggest anyone that is learning how to
read write screenplays to read that
script is so beautifully constructed
goes back to whether the question you
had asked me which is what draw me to it
right let's loop back around to Stephen
King that incredible story that Stephen
King wrote that that captured me when I
read that in different seasons I mean it
just seized me it's one of the great
stories of all time and I thought if I'm
lucky enough to get my hands on this
thing and then lucky enough to get
somebody to recognize how good the story
is then make the movie then fantastic so
it's it's really the gift the gift that
keeps on giving is the one that Stephen
King gave us he gave that story to the
world I was able to co-opt it steal it
borrow it and then pass it on to these
guys in the form
the screenplay it's really we're all
responding to what Stephen King had
given us I think and and about this
script you know the the standard
operating procedure now in Hollywood is
somebody writes a script and then they
bring in seventeen thousand creative
executives to develop it and ruin it
right they call it making it better and
they develop it you know now how much
development did you have to deal with
precious little because I mean again
going back to Martin Martin and Liz the
the the wonderful place that they had
created this incredible you know now is
mythical in my mind and I'm sure in many
people's minds this place where a
filmmaker could really go and get their
movie made with a minimum of grief and a
minimum of having to fight for your you
know for your movie because they were
there to help you make it so development
was I you know I think the biggest
comment was easy the movie ended my
original script ended with with with
read on the bus going off to this
uncertain but hopeful future which is
how the Stephen King story ended and how
I ended the script and they said after
putting the audience through two plus
hours of hell with these characters you
might owe them a reunion at the end of
it would you please consider shooting a
reunion of some sort you know to do for
the catharsis of the early on but they
did it and then there I'm sure there
were a few other suggestions you know
that they made but they were always
incredibly reasonable reasons
suggestions and they always said the
smartest thing they could possibly say
which is and if you don't like it we're
not going to force you to use it Wow
that ending also allowed us to end about
three months shoot in st. Croix yeah
sweet a three-month shoot in Ohio in st.
Croix and syncro no I mean forgive me
but holy God that the heat the humidity
I remember thinking my brains were
leaking out my ears and then suddenly
there would be hail and then it would
then it would be a rare tornado of
tornadoes - there were a couple - it was
a brilliant brilliant location though I
mean you know all kidding aside and they
were so good to us the folks from Ohio
can I beat the [ __ ] out of me because
they're all in this row if I'm not
careful